foreign
[Music]
executive producer on dark type
what you just saw is a sneak peek of the
exciting new content coming to dark type
which we released during skulls
before we talk about that let's have a
look at what we've done over the past
six months
since launch we have worked hard to
improve the game we have delivered two
content drops and nine patches alongside
many hot fixes
some highlights include
content drop the signal where we release
a new Mission and two new weapons
patch 4 blessings of the omnisaya in
which we improve the shrine and its
modification systems
content drop tools of War would feature
an Armory upgrade with 10 additional
weapon marks and new conditions
patch number nine carts and penances
where we revamp the penances and added
new cosmetic Rewards
you're supported with the past six
months have been key in delivering these
updates and we will keep delivering more
content at a steady rate now let's have
a look at content drop rejects unite
which will release during schools
[Music]
two New Missions will be added to the
game the first one archiving secrets we
see your team dispatch to wipe out
sensitive data from The Archives
a session Riser 31 will be part of our
first Community event players we have to
unite to go through three challenges
each granting rewards the final reward
will be Ascension riser 31.
an old friend will also be added to the
game
the chaos fan
alongside this additional content we
will have more quality of life
improvements and Bug fixes added into
the game with patch number 10 a new shop
dedicated to earnable Cosmetics will
open on the Morning Star featuring
additional items to collect
you can now see all ironable cosmetics
in your inventory including those left
to unlock
thank you for playing Dark type
until next time